we don't do who he'd love he wouldn't
exist I'm good
it's like nothing really matters to him
right now
including me you gotta think real hard
about this do you have people that need
you no I'm taking the fight
Victor Drago son of Ivan Drago who
infamously kill Apollo Creed appeared
today to issue a challenge to Adonis
Creed
don't do this ain't got a choice that's
the same thing your father said you died
right here in my hands
that kid was raised in Haiti
dangerous he broke things to me that I
never been fixed today worth it is not
just us anymore of day I want to rewrite
history if you want to fight this man
that's your business
but don't pretend this is about your
father
this here is all about my kids
then I'll do tonight it was right
without
[Music]
the tribulation
this won't be the end of me
are you
they can't because we a team
[Music]
now you know what you fight before
[Music]
Wow after brow you learn more about
yourself when I stepped in Henry it
wasn't all about me
[Music]
you